strich unter die innenpolitik und wollen
auf das schauen was im moment in
weißrussland passiert die bilder von
dort sind gewaltig die uns da seit gut
einer woche erreichen heute abend gab es
eine großdemonstration der auf der
straße das sind menschen mit sehr sehr
viel mut weil sie sehr sehr schlimmes
befürchten müssen als oppositionelle
oder als diejenigen die gegen den
diktator dort demonstrieren gehen gegen
lukaschenko das sind aktuelle bilder
dort aus linz aus der hauptstadt von
weißrussland und dort wollen wir jetzt
einmal schalten zu meinen kollegen paul
ronzheimer der diese proteste heute sehe
ich vor ort angeschaut hat und voller
eindrücke von diesem großdemonstration
zurückgekommen ist paul schilder uns ein
bisschen etwas über die stimmung dort
auf den straßen und vor allen dingen
auch auf die über die aussichten dieser
protest ist ja ich bin in der tat gerade
eben erst zurückgekommen von den
demonstrationen die große angst der
demonstranten hier in linz ist dass es
wieder gewalt gibt und liefert neben mir
sitzt jemand er diese gewalt erlebt hat
es ist alexis 23 jahre alte
mechatroniker in der demonstration alles
erklären was dir passiert es zeigt uns
was dir passiert ist - unser schönster
harmonie und müssen die potsdamer das
komplette bisswunde für die studierenden
sind sie ist überall schrill war jedes
menschen und wo wir schneiden dass ein
intervall gestern the wall
ja alex hat uns diese dramatischen
erlebnisse geschildert ja dort auf der
polizeiwache erlebt hat er wurde
festgenommen auf einer demonstration
wurde mit einem polizeitransporter in
eine dunkle kammer gebracht dort habe
auf ihn eingeschlagen mit einem
gummiknüppel man hat ihm eine 15 auf den
oberschenkeln mal und gleichzeitig hier
man sieht es auch seinem pullover diese
15 hat man dort brauchst du mal was man
gesagt hat alex du hast jetzt keinen
namen mehr
du hast noch nur noch eine nummer hat
man halt gesagt du musst jetzt brüllen
alexander schenk kurz der erste
präsident der welt dass man sieht wie
kräfte sind hier zu allem bereit und
wenn ich mit alex den ich gestern das
erste mal getroffen habe spreche oder
wenn ich mit den demonstranten auf der
straße spreche dann fragen sie was tut
deutschland eigentlich was kann
deutschland tun und die frage gerichtet
auch an den vizekanzler wie cannes oder
scholz niemanden wie alex schützen und
vor allem wie kann er dafür sorgen dass
derjenige der hier wahlbetrug begangen
hat alexander lukaschenko endlich
abtritt herrsche jetzt gibt mir direkt
heute die frage von paulus minsk das
erste ist dass wir jetzt europäische
union gemeinsam handeln das ist sehr gut
dass es erste beschlüsse zu sanktionen
gegeben hat die die außenminister
miteinander getroffen haben weil es
zeigt dass wir nicht akzeptieren dass
dort geschieht ich finde man kann das
schon sehr klar beschreiben der
lukaschenko hat keine mehrheit mehr in
seinem volk es durch und wenn es nur
nach demokratischen regeln gibt geht
dann wird er nicht mehr lange im amt
sein und wir müssen jetzt gewissermaßen
mit dem was wir machen dafür sorge
tragen dass die kraft und der mut
dann ist es ja ein unglaublicher mut den
ganz viele drei jeden tag gegenwärtig
zeigen dass dieser mut auch seine kraft
entfalten kann und dass es möglich ist
dadurch auch veränderungen zu sie haben
gesagt wenn es nach demokratischen
regeln geht ich glaube das können wir
nach den bildern endgültig sagen dass
das nicht der fall das ist nicht der
fall
das ist ein schlimmer diktator und
deshalb braucht er auch klare abends
eine klare sprache aber sind wir alle
das war ja die frage auch von paul und
offenbar auch von ganz ganz vielen die
da so mutig wie sie es beschrieben haben
auf die straße gehen sind wir selber
oder ist unsere sind unsere regierung
hier in europa mutig genug wenn wir
diese bilder von den hunderttausenden
dort auf der straße sehen sind wir dann
mutig genug nach einer woche zu sagen
beraten jetzt mal über sanktionen ist
das alles können sie sagen da haben wir
alles getan die zu unterstützen dort in
minsk wir müssen entschlossen und klar
sein
die beschlüsse der außenminister werden
sicherlich nicht das letzte sein was wir
zu tun haben und die ganze zeit bei
dieser linie bleiben ich glaube das ist
die sprache die jetzt verstanden werden
muss und das ist unsere möglichkeit die
dort existiert das wir zeigen so geht
das nicht und man kann mit dieser
vorgehensweise nicht durchkommen also
ganz konkret sanktionen müssen erfolgen
in welcher härte welche sanktionen das
muss hier wird es ganz konkret abgewogen
werden
man muss ja auch noch immer noch was zu
tun haben wenn man gewissermaßen das
macht denn ich stelle mir vor dass das
schon eine längere zeit sein wird und
das was wir tun können ist eben klar zu
sein entschieden zu sein und deshalb bin
ich froh das erste entscheidung
getroffen worden sind